une échelle de temps
s'entendre science
sans temps de révolution
est bien parti
plus courte il y à 35 ans je courrais
derrière la fusée ariane pour mesurer
l'impact de l'est sur l'écosystème le
changement les évolutions et au travers
de ses évolutions pendant 35 ans
comme la cité olivier on était dans une
science qui était établie la
communication donc on met des moyens
matériels pour pouvoir obtenir des
résultats
on n'est pas toujours dans cette échelle
de temps et on est convaincu que c'est
35 ans qui sont passées jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
l'évolution a été très très forte très
pesant très prégnante en 2016 on a
commencé à parler de smart alors le
smart on le met un peu à toutes les
sauces on en parle smart building
smart
innovation' smart smart smart card moi
je crois que c'est une voiture donc le
smart en fait on s'est aperçu que la
smart city c'était un besoin croissant
de mettre en place des moyens et sans
vraiment se poser la question sans se
dire pourquoi et en effet restart
donc 2016 la première avancée une
avancée lente ou mais un mot smart city
pour pouvoir définir l'aménagement
urbain mais c'est l'aménagement urbain
on l'a pris comme un moyen
donc on a vu cette évolution et puis en
parallèle de cette évolution
en 2007 un brillant un visionnaire
sortie
l'iphone mais bien évidemment il y avait
d'autres smartphones moi je viens de la
génération du minitel la génération du
radiocom 2000 quand j'ai expliqué mes
stagiaires je suis par les militaires
ils marient avec des grands yeux dans
dix ans mais je croyais qu'il y avait
dans les musées
donc cette notion de smart c'était tout
simplement la possibilité d'accéder à
l'information
donc depuis
2007 on s'est posé la question se dire
mais très bien mais à quoi je peux
accéder à quoi donc il me faut des
réseaux des réseaux de communication
donc on était toujours un peu contraint
un peu forcé à se dire mais dans un
territoire bien c'est un espace qui est
dans un espace fermé ces espaces fermés
on a de plus en plus de gens qui
viennent avec une culture différente des
ethnies différentes des âges différents
et puis bien comment faire cohabiter un
peu tout cela on s'est dit on va mettre
des moyens donc on va améliorer
nourrisons donc on va pouvoir
communiquer encore plus fort en
communiquer beaucoup plus vite donc on
va mettre des parties de la 2g et la 3g
et la 4g la 5g le wifi
on est parti avec le développement de la
fibre optique tout ça ce sont que des
moyens à aucun moment on s'est posé la
question du pourquoi mais surtout du
pour qui
donc on invente en 2016 le terme de
smart ont fait un grand balayage de tous
nos préjugés on se dit lassé d'une
solution technique et puis bien on va
résoudre tous ces problèmes citoyens de
ces problèmes humains avec des moyens
techniques et on va mettre des capteurs
on va développer avec la grande avancée
des réseaux 800 tués guerre l'avancé
donc de layati des objets connectés et
puis on va vous dire que globalement on
aura à peu près 5000 objets connectés
dans une maison d'ici 2030
les objets connectés on les a partout
partout ne sont pas eux qui ont
révolutionné vraiment la notion de smart
ce qui a résonné sur la notion de sparte
c'est tout simplement l'implication
citoyenne et là on a commencé à se dire
mais c'est un pas très longtemps il ya
trois ans seulement vous parlez toujours
de star city
regardez le marketing territorial
aujourd'hui on parle de territoire
intelligent
voire villes intelligentes au départ
c'est un petit peu pompeux donc on s'est
dit on va faire un territoire
intelligent qu'est ce qui a fait ce
changement c'est tout simplement
l'appropriation et surtout la force qui
a donné cet accès cette évolution
humaine vers le smartphone qui a donné
l'accès aux citoyens et qui a donné
l'accès au besoin un smartphone c'est
quoi ces téléphones bien évidemment
c'est la fonction première je peux dire
que quand je vois mon fils j'ai
l'impression qu'il a oublié que c'était
fait pour téléphoner
c'est une console de jeu c'est un
appareil photo c'est c'est un baladeur
c'est en fait c'est un énorme et route
fonction mais ce qui a fait la grande
avancée c'est surtout la capacité de
pouvoir accéder à un monde en permanence
et donc on s'est dit bien voilà
maintenant on a construit les zones
urbaines avec une densification on a
construit une population qui est forgée
à l'utilisation du smartphone donc ça va
marcher et non toujours pas
on est sur une échelle de temps d'une
petite échelle de temps qui est la
mienne 35 ans l'évolution ou là j'ai
vraiment un restart on parlait là d'une
évolution de la science de 100 ans
l'adéquation et saintes il n'y a que
deux ans réellement que l'on s'est mis à
comprendre que l'objectif d'un
territoire intelligent ce sont les
acteurs de ce territoire qui composent
ce territoire et là vous avez profusion
de solutions les solutions pour
rapprocher les personnes les solutions
pour pouvoir ou mieux vous déplacer
mieux vous garer une économie une
économie est née une économie forte
l'économie ou maintenant un particulier
va louer sa place de garage va louer sa
voiture va mettre à disposition des
vêtements et c'est donc toute cette
notion que l'on a toujours tendance à
mettre dans l'univers du e-commerce
l'univers de l'usaj de la consommation
c'est le territoire intelligent on
parlait de religion le partage
d'informations on parlait de de douleur
tout à l'heure on parlait de
d'agressivité
sur les réseaux sociaux la vitesse et la
profusion donc c'est ce restart dont on
parle tout simplement c'est qu'on a
compris que depuis trois ans c'est avant
tout l'implication le collaboratif et
surtout de pouvoir faire travailler
l'instance politique c'est à dire le
territoire en tant que tel en tant que
structure qui était gérée sous forme de
silos les collectivités
toujours travailler d'une manière où
j'ai bien la personne qui s'occupe de
l'arrosage la personne qui va s'occuper
de l'éclairage public la personne qui va
s'occuper des guerres de silos qui sont
très complexes pour tous les gens qui
essaient de travailler dans le monde du
territoire intelligent alors que le
territoire intelligent c'est une
fonction transverse et c'est une
fonction transverse soit l'été il faut
d'abord s'interroger sur sa propre
initiative
donc le territoire intelligent
il manque un maillon dans la chaîne dans
l'adn c'est la pédagogie tout simplement
il était essentiel de pouvoir
mettre en relation le public c'est à
dire l'usagé et les moyens dans la
mobilité aujourd'hui je me déplace tout
le monde s'élève à sa guise pas
seulement pour détecter les radars tout
le monde se déplace avec une
optimisation le covoiturage donc pour
pouvoir communiquer entre le territoire
qui est une démarche globale où
l'objectif étant d'améliorer les
fonctions d'améliorer le mieux vivre
ensemble bien toutes ces solutions ont
été mises en place
par l'avènement du smartphone mais
derrière il ya un problème d'identité ce
citoyen est ce qu'il existe vraiment et
ce qu'il peut s'exprimer il ya des pays
en estonie aujourd'hui le vote on est en
plein déduction le vote est un vote
numérique dire vous votez avec l'autre
vous avez vu les scores les derniers
scores là des initiatives ils sont peu
brillant pour autant si on mettait un
smartphone qui est un usage permanent 98
% de taux de détention
avec des réseaux qu'ils soient des
réseaux accessibles on aurai je peux
vous garantir un vote différent donc
comment impliquer ce citoyen dans cette
nouvelle ville dans ce smart territoire
dans cette ville intelligente dans ce
territoire intelligent c'est juste
prendre conscience que l'intelligence et
au niveau des citoyens à condition lui
apporter la pédagogie c'est un petit peu
ce que les cette évolution qu'on est en
train de faire depuis ces deux trois
dernières années parce qu'on a pris
conscience que bien d'avoir des moyens
sans implication ça ne sert à rien
à condition de ne pas perdre son
identité dans le numérique un citoyen
est un homme actif regardez le nombre de
démarches aujourd'hui qui sont faites à
partir de d'internet la
dématérialisation des services comme on
l'appelle c'est pas uniquement un
facteur économique regardez je sais mes
enfants je dois expliquer que le péage
qui me poser la question comment ça
marche chez l'avant niveau des gens qui
étaient derrière lui donner un ticket on
a évolué tous ces rappels sont là pour
nous rappeler que le futur est encore
devant la grande différence c'est que
dans le territoire intelligent on veut
en faire partie on râle très vite en
soyons bon gaulois bon français on est
bien râler mais ce qui est important
c'est aujourd'hui d'être constructif et
donc cet outil entre la relation il faut
pas perdre le moi et moi lorsque
j'appelle le moi et moi
c'est un propos qui est très simple
c'est que on est cette image qu'on
véhicule que l'on met sur les réseaux
sociaux
aujourd'hui on a difficulté à à laisser
ses coordonnées son adresse mail à la
collectivité qui est garant de la
sécurité de vos données
pour autant on les laisse sur nos
enfants aller sur tik tok sur les
comptes étrangers donc ce mois numérique
plomb projette est ce moi qui est la
réalité cette opposition il faut
aujourd'hui la combattre aller beaucoup
plus loin en disant mais je veux
m'impliquer donc si je veux m'impliquer
je dois être responsable donc ce
territoire intelligent c'est bien vous
qu'ils construisaient ce n'est pas de la
smart city mon propos est relativement
simple si vous voulez construire votre
propre univers à la maison vous
maîtrisez votre univers votre univers il
est beaucoup plus grand on l'a vu il est
infiniment grand on sait qu'on a une
évolution cette évolution on est obligé
de la compagnie donc lorsque vos enfants
aujourd'hui viennent vous expliquer
comment fonctionne le réglage de la
télévision lorsque vos enfants sont
aujourd'hui des consommateurs des as
peur change de chaîne etc il faut aussi
les sensibiliser sur la notion de
territoire ce territoire c'est l'espace
dans lequel vous êtes de dire bonjour à
votre voisin de garder un sens humaniste
et c'est justement la nouvelle démarche
marty d'être présent est ce que c'est un
restart est ce que c'est un reset est ce
que c'était un rêve y volent les trois
options sont possibles c'est juste vous
qui construisaient votre territoire
c'est vous qui en fait la qualité qui en
fait la composition en allant vers
l'autre donc cet humanisme qui existent
au travers des territoires il est simple
le territoire est une dimension
qui est à la grandeur de votre démarche
de votre volonté donc le smart city n'a
pas tout réglé
le territoire intelligent ne va pas tout
régler c'est juste l'avenir qu'on va
décider de s'approprier dans notre
espace pour pouvoir régler les problèmes
merci beaucoup